all right the lucifer finale but first i
want to thank the sponsor of this video
this video is brought to you by
scentbird scentbird's a fragrant
subscription that gives you the
opportunity to shop from over 600 brands
they hooked me up with omaha's
journeyman dolce gabbana k as well as
delta and gabbana the one for men what
does the one for men smell like here we
go smelling great actually you know what
it's it's fitting it's in a silver vial
cause i'm gonna call it silver fox i'm
gonna call it steven strange there it is
it's a solid amount too i mean it's not
just like a sample it's a sample this is
a nice mix between quantity and quality
you get the best of both worlds also
good news for my canadian subscribers
scentbird's expanding from the us only
to also canada we can all smell good
while we stay home and
game so click the link below be sure to
use my promo code jj for 30 off your
first month that's 11 bucks for your
first month also i haven't been called
jj since kindergarten and now this
comment section and now forever and
thank you once again to scentbird for
sponsoring this video i do appreciate it
and now it's done we've concluded this
devilishly good time i'm gonna miss it
for nothing else definitely for that
theme song
[Music]
so lucifer is a show that was canceled
after season three then netflix put on
their cape they swooped in and they
saved the day they picked lucifer up and
we got six full seasons first a little
recap of my thoughts about lucifer as a
whole at least when it started out
lucifer was the living embodiment of
benefit of the doubt cause right when it
came out through season one it's benefit
of the doubt is what kept it going well
that and tom ellis let's face it let's
be real tom ellis's screen presence and
charisma as the character lucifer
morningstar definitely got it picked up
for season two if you're not gonna
respect the man crush going on here at
least recognize the objective fact that
dude just oozes on-screen personality
on-screen presence charisma but in
season one i don't feel like i'm alone
it was more about what the show could be
if they kept it going and i'm glad they
did because we saw a lot of that we saw
a lot of it come to pass come to
fruition all this is to say i've really
enjoyed my time with the show lucifer
first of all right out the gate i'm
gonna warn you there's gonna be some
spoiler-ish things in here not gonna
break it down play-by-play i'm not gonna
be like hey by the way the end is this
not gonna do that but there are some
things where i was like i didn't say
that in the promotional material so i
don't know if it is maybe it's not that
spoiler-ish but you know there's a
character in here i want to talk about
and
it's kind of important it's the plot of
season six as a whole so we're the last
season left off this whole fight happens
with lucifer and michael a bunch of
angels siding with michael or lucifer
and lucifer wins and right now he's
gonna be god which immediately worried
me i didn't want lucifer to be god i
like lucifer being lucifer i like him
being the devil so i was really worried
about this season but luckily in this
season it doesn't start out there it's
like oh no he's not god yet he hasn't
ascended the throne and there are other
things to deal with maybe he doesn't
want to go in half cup i should
definitely be full cocked of those
things to sort out a new character comes
on the scene played by brianna
hildebrand who is lucifer's daughter
from the future which saying it out loud
i'm like yeah did you guys get that like
okay so that's it's season of the flash
essentially because it's very cw flash
that was my initial thought when she
first came on the scene but they do
enough for it to actually work for
lucifer's character her character
chloe's character because she's also
chloe's daughter cause the show's always
been about family and more specifically
relationships relationships with people
that's not to say specifically romantic
relationships just relationships you
know the show does a good job at having
the show be a mirror of
human interaction in the world as it
should be romantic relationships sibling
relationships father-son relationship
and conflict and although we've seen
father-son conflict between lucifer and
god we haven't seen daughter-father
conflict when her father is the son in
the father-son conflict that we already
saw it does its part to keep it feeling
fresh enough to where you're like oh
it's not a complete rehash and there's
the allegory of like you know everyone
always says hey i'm not going to be like
my parents and then guess what happens
right don't want to spoil the ending of
that story of life
but
where you think it might go is very well
where it might go but on the other side
of that there's the more interesting
conversation of like well what was the
intent behind the parental decisions
that led to that angst also they did a
neat thing with dan because in the
previous season dan got killed which
it's not the fact that he got killed the
fact that he's in hell like dude if
dan's going to hell where am i going
dude in the lore of the show it's like
what sends you to hell is your guilt
which doesn't seem too smart it's like
you mean if psychopaths kill people and
don't feel guilt they don't go to hell
they get to go to heaven that doesn't
seem like an airtight system so dan's
back on earth but kind of like patrick
swayze from ghost only angels and demons
celestial beings they can see and hear
him so i thought that was pretty clever
in terms of den working stuff out for
himself and also he's that fly on the
wall he gets to see and hear everything
and no one even knows linda remains the
smartest person in the show she's the
ones like she's just shaking her head
the entire time like i can't believe it
how
how are angels and demons every bit as
stupid as human beings every
psychologist psychiatrist and therapist
out there do you ever think to yourself
like i should have been a veterinarian
one would think you do and as i thought
i have once in a while i'm like man i i
don't know how you do it but you do
thank you for that not everything flows
so smoothly there are some things thrown
into this season where i'm like did you
did you have a bigger plan
but this was your final season i would
use that excuse but this is season six i
mean the goldilocks zone like the
threading the needle the peak amount of
seasons for a show i know six seasons in
a movie that's the joke but star trek
the next generation showed me seven
seasons is more or less that's peak's
success so in season six when you bring
in adam just to have him there for a bit
and it's like okay now we had adam as in
adam and eve adam well you don't do much
with him it just seems like a waste like
did you want to bring him in later in
what season eight that wasn't gonna
happen for lucifer you could have done
some interesting stuff but he gets
brought in to be a complete and total ub
nozzle who's there to learn a few
lessons about how not to be a
misogynistic [ __ ] i was like okay i
learned the lessons great i don't know
it feels like he was shoehorned into
this season because they had to have
that lesson in there but he stands out
as that thing was like hey what doesn't
entirely fit
him they do a neat thing with ella lopez
in this season which again showing that
she's one of the more complex characters
in the entire show they didn't think
last season where it's like you mean you
have serial killer tendencies and they
don't do anything else with that it's
just okay i guess she has serial killer
tendencies
i guess they just kind of breezed past
that thank you for throwing those dexter
vibes at me for a hot second but in this
season they they go with direction that
i'm glad they went it'd be in the final
season i didn't feel like there was
anything to lose only things to gain
with her character
um going this direction i liked it
chloe's the character where for years
they've been trying to figure out what
to do with her because she's lucifer's
love interest for the first three years
three seasons the whole like oh will
they won't they is she gonna figure out
that he's the devil is she not and when
netflix took over actually at the end of
the season right before it was canceled
then netflix took over she saw his devil
face then after that it's like okay
sweet that now she knows and even after
that i was like all right so she's
lucifer's love interest but do they
really know what to do with her but in
this final season she had a couple of
moments a couple of really emotional
moments that come from the fact that
she's dealing with her daughter that's
here from the future again saying it out
loud just sounds ridiculous for the show
because everything's time travel now i
guess that's been opened up when in
doubt time travel whether it's her and
her daughter or her and dan and dan is
there but she can't see dan she has a
couple of moments where they bring the
emotion to her character and even by the
end of the show
i had this feeling of fulfillment like
fulfillment with her character the show
was dangerously close as it was wrapping
up in the final season in season six
like near the end it was like we're at
the end game and i might not be
fulfilled with this show but when it
came to lucifer's character chloe's
character who's gonna take over heaven
as god
all of that when it wrapped up i had
this really rare feeling of fulfillment
not a lot of shows give me that not a
lot of shows give anyone that think of
how many shows dropped the ball in the
last season exactly there are a lot of
shows out there that just like i guess
the weight of it all is just too heavy
but with lucifer
it always felt like the writers the cast
the crew everybody involved in
production they all appreciated the time
they had they didn't take it for granted
they were never on top of mount olympus
here like you know we're looking down on
all the other shows like crap it's our
world and so we can do no wrong that
hubris makes it all crumble down like a
house of cards or something it never
felt like that it always felt like they
wanted to do right by the characters and
the fans and when they weren't doing
right by a character they really tried
their best to make that character work
and in the case with chloe a character i
didn't always connect with and felt like
okay it's lucifer show and his
girlfriend i felt like by the end of
this show there was a huge feeling of
fulfillment where i'm like oh yeah
chloe's very important in fact she
carries a lot on her shoulders the show
didn't always give me that feeling with
her character but i'm glad it left me
with that feeling with her character and
in the end the final season of lucifer i
really enjoyed i had a blast with it's
one of those seasons that i can point to
and be like that is the reason i enjoy
the show lucifer and as much as i can
safely say that some of my favorite
moments in the show were when lucifer
was being his devilishly hedonistic self
and enjoying doing so i am undeniably
fulfilled in their sixth season long
game lesson with his character which is
if the devil can grow
any of us can if you haven't checked out
the show i absolutely recommend it if
you're only litmus test for the show
lucifer is the first season you were
like and not for me it is the rockiest
it was like yeah season one didn't grab
me be like i get it season three had
some good stuff but i really felt like
the show found its energy and found its
stride in season four when netflix took
over i mean many shows out there
entertain
not very many shows actually stick the
landing of the wrap-up of the conclusion
the finale leave you feeling fulfilled
i'll always love lucifer for that and
the years of entertainment all right so
lucifer have you seen it what did you
think about it what's your favorite
season of the show at all whatever it is
whatever you think comment below let me
know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
[Music]
you